james not your typical offensive night
but that defensive stuff you let out a
scream
afterwards what were you feeling at that
moment
offensively i feel like [ __ ] excuse my
language but
i couldn't make a shot uh turn the ball
over just doing everything that
was not supposed to happen but i just
kept sticking with it you know my
teammates gave me confidence
uh throughout the course of games and uh
defensively i had to make it play and i
tried to close out to him dory has been
knocking down some shots
uh tonight so i want to get out to him
your teammates stepped up in this one
how would you describe how you guys
gutted this game out together and it was
frenetic down the stretch
give oklahoma city credit man they play
hard scrappy
uh very very guard oriented get to the
basket
they just fought they gave us a seven
game series down to the last possession
uh you know but guys stuck with it you
know it was it was a possession by
possession game
and that's what's gonna happen in the
playoffs so we made the right play down
the stretch and win the game
yeah you guys were able to withstand an
okc team who continues to come up in the
clutch
how would you describe this battle
against your former teammate cp3 here in
a game seven
like i said they scrappy you know cb
made some big shots especially in the
fourth quarter
um you know shea they're they're all
their guards man they make plays and so
we want to contain the dribbling and
contest shots when we had to and then uh
at the end of the position rebounding
the basketball so i think we did a
really good job especially towards the
end of the game
and um just happy to come up with the
win lastly just
two days you have until you face a
well-rested lakers team
yeah and lebron james who you haven't
gone up against since you were in the
finals last with the thunder
yeah so what are you anticipating about
that matchup uh superstar power
you know they've been playing well and
obviously you know the first round
uh they played extremely well uh you
know two days and we got another game so
we just got to get our rest
i'm sure we're watching from tomorrow
and up and get ready to go
congrats on the series win james back to
you mark
and hit the ice tub too cassie